what's up guys is a sure angel we got
some fan questions yeah let's do it
et laughs let's go I started off doing
musical theater I did that for four
years and tried to convince my parents
taking out here to like you know try to
make it big and they weren't convinced
yet so I did like three more years of
musical theater eventually worked my way
up to a professional theater and they
were convinced and I came out here first
pilot season and Buck booked a couple
guest stars here and there and like my
first series regular and then somehow
did music and then ran into this amazing
project called as I am and I am living I
love it Shazam
immediately uh uh hopefully soon I mean
that's that's the dream that's that's
the that's what we're trying to do I'm
in the studio every day recording new
music so playing this to release an EP
or an album very soon I wish I could
tell you when but I don't know when but
soon I don't really get nervous I'm it's
mostly just excitement because I'm just
as excited to get out there and just
hopefully kill it I don't really get
nervous like I'm just always excited and
like happy that I get to do this when we
delia like these weird like chants
things oh yeah
start it up boom boom yeah ignore them
yeah block out theatres there's always
the people that there's always gonna be
people that don't you know wanting to
put you down but you know just got to
block it out be you you can't do that
and just stay away from social media my
parents the people that I surround
myself with um I wouldn't be where I am
without my parents and my friends I just
surround yourself with good people
stress no stress not only sometimes but
no I wouldn't say that I mean just work
hard I mean I don't think there's ever
like never really stressed I guess so I
guess just I don't know I'm not really
stress can we just uh
[Music]
that's my boy Khalid yeah love talk
killing it walking onto that private jet
was pretty amazing like getting the film
when that was amazing and then also
driving the golfcart
yeah I got to do that well I attempted
to do that I got in trouble that's still
fun thank you so much for watching a
sure angel eat see live see you guys
next
[Music]